Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quando ero un’adolescente,
criticavo mio padre.
Lo criticavo per tante cose,
come fanno spesso gli adolescenti;
ma una delle cose per cui lo criticavo
era che lui non butta via mai niente.
Anche un oggetto vecchio, rotto, usurato,
scheggiato per lui aveva un valore.
Se non in quel momento,
in un momento successivo,
quando lui poi lo avesse aggiustato.
Cosa che non succedeva mai,
e quindi noi ci trovavamo la casa sommersa
di piccoli e grandi oggetti rotti.
Be', la cosa più pazzesca
è che, dopo averlo criticato tanto,
io mi ritrovo a fare, in età adulta,
esattamente come fa lui.
Non riesco a buttare via niente.
Be', forse è per questo
che la mia attenzione
è caduta su un articolo
che parlava del Kintsugi.
Il Kintsugi è un’arte giapponese.
Letteralmente, riparare con l’oro -
da “Kin”, oro, e “Tsugi”, riparare.
È un’arte che utilizza una lacca speciale,
con dentro delle polveri d'oro,
per riparare degli oggetti
che vengono rotti,
utilizzando poi il prezioso metallo
per coprirne i punti di giunzione.
Questa tecnica permette di ottenere
degli oggetti preziosi,
sia dal punto di vista economico,
per via della presenza dell'oro,
sia dal punto di vista artistico,
perché ogni oggetto
diventa unico e irripetibile,
per via della casualità
con cui la ceramica si rompe,
e quindi per via delle variegate
e ramificate decorazioni
che si formano sull'oggetto,
e che vengono poi evidenziate dall’oro.
Beh, io voglio aggiungere che, secondo me,
la preziosità dell'oggetto
aumenta, soprattutto,
per il valore del tempo,
dell'attenzione e della cura
che si è messi per
aggiustare questo oggetto.
Pensate che in Giappone esiste proprio
la figura del maestro di Kintsugi.
E un oggetto riparato
da un rinomato maestro
arriva a valere e costare parecchio.
Perché?
Perché si creano delle vere
e proprie opere d'arte, sempre diverse.
Ognuna con la propria trama da raccontare.
Ognuna con la propria bellezza da esibire,
proprio in virtù della propria rottura
e di come si è frantumata.
Beh, noi oggi che cosa facciamo?
Quando un oggetto si rompe,
ha perso la sua integrità.
Lo buttiamo, non lo ripariamo.
Ne compriamo uno nuovo.
È il consumismo.
Facciamo così anche
con le relazioni, ormai.
Ma guardate come può essere bello,
invece, un oggetto riparato
con i suoi punti di rottura
evidenziati, e non nascosti.
Noi, se aggiustiamo qualcosa,
lo facciamo prendendo
una colla trasparente,
stando bene attenti
a non far vedere i punti di giunzione.
Non si deve vedere
che l'oggetto si è rotto.
Beh, comunque... prima cosa,
il Kintsugi mi dà ragione:
non bisogna buttare via niente,
che poi ci ritroviamo
con qualche cosa di più prezioso.
Ma soprattutto mi aveva colpito.
Mi aveva colpito tanto
da salvare una cartella sul desktop
e andare a prendere maggiori informazioni.
Il Kintsugi nasce in Giappone
nel periodo muromachi,
sotto lo shogunato di Yoshimasa,
nella seconda metà del Quattrocento.
È questo un periodo molto fertile
sotto il profilo culturale,
e molte sono le arti
che vengono importate,
soprattutto dalla Cina, in Giappone.
Arti come il teatro nō,
la cerimonia del tè,
l'arte di comporre
i fiori recisi, l'ikebana.
Tutte facenti parte
di una corrente culturale
che si basa sul Buddhismo Zen.
Questa corrente culturale
si chiama Wabi-Sabi.
Wabi-Sabi racconta
della semplicità della natura.
Dell'accettazione, dell'imperfezione
e del difetto, senza nasconderli.
E dell'accettazione del passare del tempo,
che porta a una serenità interiore.
La leggenda racconta
che fu proprio Yoshimasa
che ruppe la tazza
per la cerimonia del tè preferita,
e volle a tutti i costi
che fosse aggiustata.
Provarono prima
i maestri ceramisti cinesi,
ma il risultato non venne bene;
poi provarono i maestri
ceramisti giapponesi,
e appunto inventarono
questa lacca particolare
che diventa molto forte,
una volta asciutta.
Insomma, il risultato
piacque tantissimo a Yoshimasa,
e quindi il Kintsugi
prese piede in Giappone.
Cosa succede quindi?
In Giappone, se una vecchia tazza
si rompe, non si butta.
Si ripara.
Dandole una nuova vita,
rendendola ancora più bella e preziosa.
Rendendola una vera e propria opera d'arte
che proprio in virtù della propria rottura
ha una storia da raccontare.
Be'...
e noi?
Quando siamo noi, a romperci?
Quando andiamo in mille pezzi,
e pensiamo che non riusciremo mai
a mettere insieme i cocci?
Quando succede qualche cosa
che ci rompe nel corpo e nell'anima?
Usiamo dire “ho il cuore a pezzi”
e succede che perdiamo la speranza
nella vita, nel futuro.
Perdiamo la fiducia in noi stessi.
L'intero è rotto.
I pezzi sono sparsi.
La vita che c’era prima, non ci sarà più.
La frattura sembra irrimediabile.
(Applausi)
Che fatica!
Ma che risultati.
È stato proprio in un momento
doloroso della mia vita
che sono andata a riaprire
quella cartella sul desktop,
e l'ho guardata in modo più approfondito.
La filosofia giapponese
va oltre la riparazione di un oggetto.
Il Kintsugi suggerisce
paralleli suggestivi.
Non bisogna buttare ciò che si rompe.
La rottura di un qualche cosa
non ne genera più la fine,
e i suoi punti di rottura
diventano trame preziose.
Bisogna cercare
di recuperare, e non mollare.
Questa è l'essenza della resilienza.
In Occidente,
la sofferenza è considerata
un sentimento sterile
e non un moto dell'anima
attraverso il quale ciascuno di noi
può arrivare a comprendere
meglio sé stesso
e reinventarsi ridisegnando
la propria esistenza.
La vita è integrità e rottura insieme,
ed è ricomposizione costante ed eterna.
Ciascuno di noi deve cercare
di far fronte positivamente
ad eventi traumatici
e crescere attraverso
le proprie esperienze dolorose.
Valorizzandole ed evidenziandole,
e convincersi che è
proprio grazie a queste
che siamo diventate delle persone uniche.
È proprio grazie agli ostacoli
che abbiamo superato,
i traumi che abbiamo subito
e le sofferenze che abbiamo sperimentato
che siamo diventati
più preziosi e più ricchi.
La caduta, la frattura
ti stanno dando una visione della vita
che, se fossi rimasto intatto,
non avresti avuto.
Sta a noi scegliere di dipingere
le nostre difficoltà con l’oro.
Il dolore, elaborato, passa,
e ci lascia cambiati.
A volte più forti, a volte più saggi,
ma in ogni caso lascia un segno.
E l'elaborazione di una ferita
è un procedimento lungo,
che necessita pazienza e amore,
ma che garantisce dei risultati
imprevisti e bellissimi,
e può rivelare aspetti nascosti
e forme nuove affascinanti.
E i punti di rottura
sono ancora più forti,
perché le linee di frattura,
riempite con l’oro,
hanno messo in luce una parte di te
che prima non conoscevi.
Non siamo mai rotti
senza possibilità di aggiustarci.
Sta a te scegliere di rialzarti,
e di imparare da quello che è successo,
e diventare una persona migliore.
E puoi scegliere di indossare
le tue cicatrici, come fossero medaglie.
Come a dire:
“Guarda quello che ho attraversato,
perché è quello che mi ha reso
la persona che sono adesso.
E ora posso attraversare
qualsiasi sfida la vita mi presenti”.
Ogni livello della tua vita
richiede un nuovo te.
E a volte, abbiamo bisogno di romperci,
per raggiungere quella
nuova versione di noi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)